here's the weird thing about your life
which I find fascinating so you're a kid
and your dad's running around with this
professional recording equipment he
makes friends with a guy named Les Paul
and anyone who knows anything about
music Les Paul was a guitar god he's the
guy who invented the electric guitar
right that's right your dad makes
friends with him invites him to your
home and he starts playing with you and
even teaching you guitar and gives you
your first guitar am i correct well
close Les Paul and Mary Ford came to
Milwaukee he was from Waukesha the
wizard from Waukesha I think was his
nickname and he had been out in
Hollywood and he'd been recording and
doing lots of stuff and he got a show a
television show in New York and it was
like one of the first shows very weird
like a 15 minute show on you know at odd
times and stuff so he and Mary came to
Milwaukee to work at a nightclub that
was just down the street from where we
lived and you're a little boy yeah yeah
and my dad went over to see les a show
and then he said you know I've got a
tape recorder do you mind if I come and
record you guys and he's blessed no
that'd be great
I'd love to hear it yeah and so what
they were doing was they were rehearsing
their act in this nightclub they're
getting paid to rehearse in Milwaukee
right so I started going with my dad to
the nightclub to see Les Paul I'd be
sitting on the stool next to him while
he had the earphones on in the tape
recorder and he'd be recording their set
when you get exposed to something like
that and you see how cool it can be yep
that's what inspires you right
absolutely thank God your father would
bring you to these shows yeah yeah
unless and Mary would come over to the
house they eventually got married at our
house my parents were the you know maid
of honor and the best man and they spent
their honeymoon and in our house and so
I got to know les you know why I you
know why I find this and I don't think
that's funny that Robin says it because
you know in my home my parents never
invited anyone over it was a very closed
thing it was it was very dark in a sense
people didn't come in and hang out or
get married and we know best friends
know and it's like your father was so
and your mother was so open to the idea
almost like a hippie kind of thing like
come on in and like it was and and it
was so cool because les always had jam
sessions
Maui's there were every time he played
she would invite somebody up on the
stage so I thought that's what it was
all about you know like you've had all
this fun you were really funny he played
guitar Mary sang great songs and
three-part harmony he was speeding the
tape up and down I figured all of this
out like in 1949 what would let's teach
you on the guitar what would he what
what type of thing you know he showed me
three chords this one
those are the three chords he shot that
so be there one finger chords and I will
eat one finger chords well are you doing
different tuning you see yeah and it
sounds good
yeah and that's where you got to start
with your first finger yo and from there
I just started making up songs and doing
stuff became English at that point that
music gets you to be the cool guy with
the cool car I mean what was it was that
I think no none of that really existed
that was all much much later you know
like I what I saw was I saw grown men
having a great time yeah you know really
really having fun and and I was just I
loved singing and playing